vaut mieux s'entraider enfants oui et
bien dès que casimir sera là on commence
vous croyez battre l'équipe de julie oui
sûr et certain oui vous êtes là bonjour
vous arrivez bien aujourd'hui grand
concours de mime entre les deux équipes
que vous voyez ça de julie est la mienne
aujourd'hui ce sera un concours de mime
d'anigo bien avant le casimir je vais
encore gagné un concours moment là qu'on
soit je saurai braquent tuent un demi
mme mois excellent qu'on verra ce serait
très difficile pour vous rassure je lis
ton équipe est prête et bien venez vous
venez on va commencer aujourd'hui on
fait des mises animé et pendant que les
mym se déroule on ne dit rien pour
laisser nos amis chercher parfait
philippe regarde bien gentil nippon et
on va essayer de trouver ce qu'il est en
train de faire elle gagne ça se fait
sans dire une parole sans parler de bien
qu'est ce qui fait pas mal
hamma jean-philippe il y en a qui ont
entouré et pour avoir trouvé car elle
n'en dit rien pour l'instant trouvé
trois ans chez eux certains de nos amis
ont sûrement déjà trouvé aussi
alors qu'est-ce que ça peut bien et
donne la réponse dans mon équipe là qui
s'arroge une vache pour arrêter ça bon
bon bon jour une équipe en séries hubert
vas-y alors vous l'avenir
devinez certaine alors l'équipe de julie
vous regardez bien ce procès le fassent
à nouveau en guerre contre alors france
alors l'équipe de julie dit je n'ai pas
la réponse tout de suite est certain
c'est sa leader
eh bien tu les gagnes toute façon
c'était un animal est parti à cannes -
minot joris boillat un ver de terre à on
est à égalité 1 pour l'instant de jean
pierre léaud coeur elle est visible au
centre pied pour bien qu'une fois et
puis tu fais ton animal oulala fait peur
bruno 81,6 et alors pascal
qu'est ce que ça serait un taureau c'est
à rouen voilà tricorps mois 2,1 alors à
viens tu vas caroline donc tu préfère
attendre parce qu'à aller pascal c'est
le meilleur pour la fin
caroline bon c'est quelle drôle de bête
pas si facile que ça trouvés
soudainement ça alors continuez encore
jusqu'à ce qu'on prouve si notre équipe
qui doit trouver alors l'équipe de juni
la poule parce que c'est ça pascal à
l'oeuf et la poule très bientôt
caroline attention faut pas répondre à
ton équipe at il acquis acquis à toi
alexis j'allais xi
j'ai trouvé il se trouvait alors il ya
une chose que mon équipier donc toi qui
attendrit no win or qu'est-ce que c'est
le latin à lapins c'était un matin ils
sont forts chez moi mais bon je dis donc
il en attentionné à lui réprouvé
pour l'instant ça sera caroline aller le
mime de bruno ces honneurs à mon équipe
bruno s'était bien préparé est ce parce
que j'espère que ça donnera envie à nos
amis chez eux de faire des mimes
on sait qu'on maniement qui s'obtient il
ya des réponses pour l'équipe de julie
allez encore un musicien il était très
bien encore espoir est vain il en
réponse alors un guépard tient à brno
c'était ça ou presque
alors encore une courte une panthère oui
c'est ça la france à rouler au pas - ste
plus que karine à l'équerré nombreuses
oh
pour prouver doit bien devant pour
qu'ils puissent voir
ah oui parce que ça tu me trouvais pas
très bien ça se bagarre chez moi pour
donner la réponse c'est pas facile ça
veut dire quelque chose le bonheur est
monté à lui continue dif 1 un éléphant
car il tient la tête un éléphant
formidable vraiment comme à l'origine
alors nous il faut qu'on devine avant
être à égalité les fasse pas là sinon
regardez bien je crois qu'il l'a déjà
qu'ils ont trouvé je continue continuer
oui matinée j'ai pas trouveront moi j'ai
pas trouvé récemment que c'est vous qui
s'en vont je crois que ton d'hannibal et
pas toujours allongé comme ça eux qui se
relève quelques fois brisée continue
alors bien ici caroline vacances c'était
sache que tu as serait formidable bond à
égalité à égalité avant de gagner il a
été aussi bien les uns que les autres
et maintenant que casino sera à moi oui
alors vous allez vraiment voir un le
plus grand mime du monde qui va vous
faire un animal extraordinaire et très
rare et bien tu peux commencer casimir
ça pourrait bien être cherchez bien ici
dans l'île aux enfants et chez vous vous
cherchez aussi quel est l'animal que
casimir est en train de diminuer c'est
pas un animal ordinaire
je vous donnais un petit tuyau il y en a
que sous l'île aux enfants des animaux
comme ça alors alors qu'est-ce que ça va
changer entre les 1400 paix alors qu'à
finir ouvrait cette espèce voilà c'est
ça salon couvrez vous verrai pour
dominer ou jean philippe
[Musique]